it's interesting over the weekend i
actually sat down and watched i wanted
to see like a bernie rally beginning to
end i know i'm i'm
really a masochist so i sat down and i
watched a burning rally beginning to end
and i want to tell you about that and i
want to talk about the appeal of bernie
sanders which i think republicans are
underestimating and really tells you
what you need to know about the
sort of bernie sanders campaign and that
is everything bernie sanders does is
about quote-unquote building a movement
if you watch one of his rallies
his from beginning to end he feels like
a 1960 style professor who's doing a
teach-in
and it's deliberately created like this
i mean this is what his rallies are
created to do
this is how he speaks he has this sort
of we're speaking up to the man
we're down we're not just here to stop
trump we're here to build a movement and
then he's very vague about what exactly
the movement constitutes
because it would be very odd if the
soviet national anthem started playing
in the background or something to give
you a clue
so he does this whole teaching mentality
and that means for example about 10 days
ago
he's at a rally in iowa or not even like
six days ago he did a rally in iowa
ames iowa and the rally opened with the
band portugal the man
playing for him very popular band i
played one of their songs on the show
there
they do catchy tunes and one of their
guys gets up
at the end of this and he says you know
when i was asked to play at this burning
rally
well i had one stipulation that every
one of our concerts we ask
indigenous people to come to the concert
and we ask them to stand up and explain
why we are standing on stolen land
he then ushers up three native american
women in ames iowa to explain
why iowa is actually stolen land right
this is the opener
of the bernie sanders rally is that we
are standing on stolen land so basically
the foundations of the united states are
evil
right that is the that is the opener at
the bernie sanders rally
then these native american women they
get up they talk about all of this
they leave and michael moore gets up and
michael moore
who is indeed a radical i mean the man
made a movie about how the
cuban healthcare system is a joy of joys
and a wonder of wonders which is why
everybody in cuba is trying to escape
from cuba
on a 1957 chevy with tires blowing up
around the sides
trying to float their way to miami which
by the way is not an easy thing to do
right 90 miles of shark infested water
is just to get away from that wonderful
health care system
that michael moore is so high on so
michael moore then gets up
and michael moore does this about how
america is founded in racism and sexism
and bigotry
and homophobia and inequality and how
bernie sanders is going to completely
revolutionize the way politics is done
right he gets up and he does his stick
for like 20 minutes
and then after that he ushers up bernie
sanders and now bernie looks like that
well actually i'm sorry then he ushers
up aoc okay aoc gets up
and she gets up and she starts talking
about how america is a corrupt system
and aoc again
is quite good on the stump right she's
charismatic and she gets up and she does
her shtick about how america
is is terrible and america is awful and
how she is for burning because bernie is
the most radical guy in the field
and then she ushers up burning and
bernie is the elder statesman right now
because you've seen
portugal the man three native american
women explaining that iowa is bad
followed by michael moore who's a crazy
person followed by aoc who's an even
crazier person when they usher up bernie
bernie seems almost moderate by
comparison with the rest of the rally
because
bernie's schtick is not the bernie that
you actually see during the debates
during the debates you got burnley
yelling all the time
about unfairness and about health care
and america is terrible
during his rallies he speaks instead
like
some sort of of uc berkeley 1968
professor
right he it's much more lower pitched
right he it's much lower pitch he gets
up and he says
we live in the country that has serious
inequality and you and i together are
going to build a movement
it sounds much more reasonable and and
it's designed like this right it's it's
actually quite clever
and again his whole shtick is we're not
just going to defeat donald trump who is
the worst person who ever lived but also
we are going to build a movement and
this is why he's got momentum right now
because joe biden's case
is only defeating trump bernie sanders
case is i'm going to build a movement
and that is a lot more inspiring
particularly to young people now older
people are going
we don't need a movement we just need to
stop trump right we don't like trump
trump's bad
but bernie is like no we're going to
stop trump and we're going to build the
movement
now make no mistake his first pitch is
we're going to stop trump and that's the
only unifying pitch he has
because the truth is that his movement
is popular with his movement
it is not popular with the bulk of
americans there was a new poll that came
out that should scare the living
daylights
out of democrats that showed what
americans think of capitalism versus
socialism
as a poll from nbc news wall street
journal released on sunday
more than half of registered voters 52
have a positive view of capitalism
18 have a negative perception of
capitalism i don't know what happened to
the other
30 percent whether they were hit in the
head by a brick or something but the
fact that you live
in the greatest economy in the history
of the world and you live in a
capitalist system that has generated
more wealth since 1800 than in the
entire history of humanity combined
and that only 52 percent of you think
that capitalism is good demonstrates a
real lack of education
in the american system but i will say
only 19
of voters have a positive view of
socialism whereas 53 have a negative
perception of socialism and bernie
sanders openly declares that he is a
socialist
right he always says democratic
socialism but he's an actual socialist
in the sense that he still cannot
explain why he would not nationalize all
of the industries he said
who would want to nationalize with that
said look bernie
right now in this poll is leading trump
nationally 49 to 45 that is not enough
to beat trump
because when all the votes come in it's
probably more like 48 trump and most of
those are in the swing states whereas
bernie is racking up big scores in
places like california
and new york and places that already
agree with bernie so if you are in the
democratic party
base and all you want to do is be trump
you're scared but
this is why the primaries are really
really a problem for for joe biden
because
the people who are voting in the
primaries are the most excited they're
the people who want to feel like they're
part of a movement they're the people
who are the most passionate the people
who are the quote unquote most
well-educated the people who follow this
stuff
the most closely and those people are in
bernie sanders's corners the primaries
are cutting directly against
the electoral interest of the democrats
now with that said
do i think that republicans who are
rooting for bernie's nomination are
underestimating him i do
i do i think that bernie is shockingly
shockingly interesting on the stump like
having again watched one of his entire
events over the over the weekend
i think he's shockingly interesting on
the stump i think that he's he's good at
what he does
which is be a useless communist for his
entire life but
give you the feeling that there's a
conspiratorial elite coming after you
which is a different thing than than
like elizabeth warren does it but it's
it's louder and it's more brash and it's
not as
weird it's weird right because if you
watch them in debate you think that that
warren is the one who's more modulated
because in debate she is
but if you watch them on the stump
warren is a lot less modulated than
sanders
sanders comes off as softer spoken on
the stump than elizabeth warren does
which is really
kind of a fascinating contrast but with
that said
is is bernie in a position where the
democratic
party upper echelon should be frightened
of him
they should they should like i think
republicans are underestimating but i
also think that it's quite possible that
bernie gets skunked by donald trump and
if you're a member of the democratic
party elite
the fact that he's building a movement
in the primaries that is not going to
carry over to the general
beyond that core is not going to be
super helpful to you
and as you'll see bernie's people are
actively alienating other elements of
the democratic party
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel so you don't miss out on
any of our content